all right boys we're gonna end it i'm a
little king of the stinger
god damn yours oh that video is [ __ ]
classic
up first we got our boy uh little bone
jones everybody oh lbj
lebon jones hey theo hey brandon
this is sebastian out of garland texas
and i got a king at her stinger
brother guys with nipple piercings
[Music]
gang gang buzz buzz
well look here's you got to get them
treated though don't get the untreated
ones because they rust
and that's what i've seen yeah you don't
want to go cheap with the nipple
piercings but also
don't do them you don't do them it's not
mtv
spring break 1997. we can't do that dude
you can't get [ __ ] tattoos and you
can't get nipple piercings
you also really can't have a long hair
like that anymore
you know what i'm saying and why is it
so wet why is his hair so
wet dude he probably just got baptized
or something man this guy looks like a
quality young fellow looks like a
patriot though i'll give him that
oh aim small miss small man this dude
would get it
done against the brits okay i'll tell
you that in the heart yeah if there's a
problem you ain't lying oh bro
he'll put the he'll put the queen in a
casket if he had to you know what i'm
saying this guy could get it done bruh
he'll
winston churchill got nothing on this
little bed the only time i like uh
piercings is if i'm at a strip club and
some girl some big old teddys
it's interesting because you look like
the kind of guy that would have your
nipples pierced really i feel like you
would
no after that rap video i feel like you
and your bro get your nipples pierced
and spend all your money on [ __ ]
chicken wings at hooters
the hooters part yeah but i'll say this
get the pre-treated ones if you do get
that pre-treated you know you don't want
the ones that
that will rust man i i remember i was at
a lake not too long ago in oklahoma and
they had a guy out there and he had
one of his nipple rings was rusted and i
was like man that's
could be vintage you got to get the
treatment on it uh on that steel
uh dude i just i don't see the benefits
to it dude
unless you're what about when the sun
hits it when you got your chest out in
the sun
that could be cool make a wolf look from
far away
what was that oh uh i got i just i don't
see the benefits man yeah
i feel like it would hurt like a
[ __ ] you've
dead serious have you had your nipple
pairs no never
never have you had that nose please i
pierced my ears a couple times no i'm
not piercing my nose dude because other
bulls will come try to [ __ ] me
so uh but
i pierced my ears probably five or six
times when i was a child you know i
might appear
up here something i had like a growth on
my hip i think we pierced it one night
pierced a mole cat you just your ears
are pierced have you
had anything else nope i am not fond
of piercings i like tattoos those are
the only type of needles i can do do you
have any tattoos
yeah you do yeah okay we went over this
i got one
on my side and then i'm getting another
one in november what do you get in
november
uh on my arm you're getting sleeved up
uh
just my forearm i feel like you look
sexy with a little nose piercing
just a little ring i thought about it
i'm i bet you'd look cool
does your sister have one no just
tattoos that surprises me
that surprises you yeah
well shout out to this guy uh uh
i'm against nipple piercings where are
you on nipple piercings i'm out it seems
like a hassle bro like tsa security you
have to take out your [ __ ] nipples
with your
shoe you know it's too much yeah
somebody will steal them too at security
they steal [ __ ]
plus your girl dimension girl's just
licking your nipple it's pierced that's
not
sexy dude i think it's brave though i
think the dude look man
this guy obviously guy likes to [ __ ]
i'll tell you that this guy will [ __ ]
outdoors and i respect that he'll put on
some [ __ ] he looks like you put on
some bruce springsteen and [ __ ] your
[Music]
brains
[Music]
i